iren Chag propose voyage sans
passeport
le rio culouen bordé de ces immenses
forêts
impénétrables et une phenda dont
l'activité est l'élevage du bétail elle
compte plus de 120000 têtes et est aussi
étendue qu'un département français bêtes
saines et robustes parfaitement bien
adapté à la chaleur du pays résultat
d'un croisement de nos vaches avec le
zébus des
Indes
au R des chevaux sont mis à la
disposition des Schwart et ensemble nous
allons parcourir sous 42 degr à l'ombre
nous en sommes loin aujourd'hui une
piste que vienent parfois rafraîchir de
petit
r un P Royal fier de son beau
plumage
un Kati très apprécié pour sa
fourrure sur les bord maricageux du
rokouen vivent en toute tranquillité
etchassiers et
palmipè et des milliers de papillons
qu'elle s'attaque ce petit serpent Isy
Schwartz nous a dit qu'il avait
rencontré là-bas en 3 mois quatre
serpents donc au fond assez peu celui-ci
avant d'avaler sa victime la broie dans
ses
anneaux il a été tué pendant qu'il
prenait son bain le pauvre ce n'est
qu'un petit anaconda les Indiens
prétendent qu'il en existe de plus de 30
m un paresseux doucement mon vieux
doucement je pour être
fatigué c'est énorme lézard aime les
chiens et vic-versa à la brousse comme à
la
brousse on boit l'eau que l'on
trouve il est parfois nécessaire de se
ner sur sa propre
chasse mais il faut vite le sortir de
l'eau car il y a des piranases qui ont
vite fait de ne laisser qu'un
squelette le tapire gibier assez rare a
une chair d'une grande finesse sa peau
est d'une épaisseur et d'une solidité
incroyable et nécessite un couteau bien
affilé ce qu'il cherche parmi les tripes
est un morceau de viande qui s'appelle
foufou et qui flotte sur l'eau on se
rend ainsi compte rapidement s'il y a
des
piranases jeune kouati capturé qui
partagent leur
repas et qui préfère un morceau de
viande grillée à la canne à
sucre et maintenant c'est l'heure de la
détente alors cigarette avec une feuille
de maïs séché et un morceau de tabat en
boudin mais qu'on achète au
maître soudain apparaît un crocodile qui
s'apprête à nager en direction du reste
du tapis rejeté à l'eau regardez bien
c'est un spectacle cruel fascinant et
fantastique
la victime victime et
dememi
aussitôt tiré les pan secoué de dernier
surceut le crocodile est une bête assez
difficile à tirer les balles ricochent
facilement sur la boîte crâenne les
points vulnérables sont la mâchoire et
les
yeux
nous nous dirigeons maintenant vers un
petit poste avancé
xavantina qui se trouve au bord du rio
de la mort et dont les rives des
limitent la dernière avance des blancs
face au territoire occupé par les
farouches indiens exavant
chemin faisant une partie de chasse
sous-marine est décidé au milieu de
grosses difficultés le peu de
transparence des eos et un courant très
très
violent première prise une raie
oselot elle possède sous la queue un
dare contenant un poison très violent et
dans la piqure peut-être
mortel un peu plus loin un coup Duriot
tire son rideau de verdure et nous
arrivons chez les
garenos
nous sommes ici parmi des fantômes
vivants du siècle passé des survivants
de la ruée vers l'or on dirait des
figurins de cinéma qui pourrai tenir des
rôles de forban ou de justiciers du Far
West et pourtant leur physique n'a rien
à voir avec leur honnêteté ils nous ont
accueilli avec un rapide signe de la
main et sans s'occuper de nous il
continu à chercher il ne parle pas
raconte Isy Schwarz pourquoi
parlerait-il puisqu'ils sont là pour
chercher il joue chaque minute avec la
misère ou la
fortune certains sont là depuis des
années en train de creuser de tamiser
changeant de temps à autre de place car
ils peuvent aller où ils veulent parmi
eux un français un ancien professeur
d'histoire pris par le dém l'aventure il
n'a plus de famille il n'a plus rien il
n'a jamais rien trouvé pour ainsi dire
juste de quoi se nourrir pour ne pas
mourir de fa mais dans chacun de ces
hommes il y a l'espoir pour ce garim
Perro cette pelletée tamisée représente
l'écrain d'une
fortune car ce petit bout de verre que
vous voyez dans le tas là sous vos yeux
là une fois taillé vaudra 8
millions quittant le rueau de la mort
enchanté nous arrivons sur le domaine
des Indiens
Galapagos c'est de ce village que le
colonel fauset fut aperçu pour la
dernière fois lorsqu'il partit à la
recherche de cette ville d'or vestige
d'une vieille civilisation dont il
affirmait l'existence englouti par la
marée verte du matau grosau ces indiens
vivent à l'âge de pierre se nourrissent
uniquement de maïs de manioc et du
produit de leur chasse et de leur
pêche les meilleurs chasseurs ont droit
selon la loi des
Galapagos à deux femmes car un bon
chasseur peut en ouvrir
deux les Indiens habitent dans des hutes
fait avec des branches de palmiers ils
leur ont offert quelques vêtements des
médicaments et de la verterie qu'ils
apprécient tout
particulièrement nous étions au point de
jonction avec Schwarz au point de
jonction qu'il s'était fixé à une autre
partie de l'expédition qui les attendait
avec avion et JEP jeep mal en point car
avant de repartir ils se sont enlisés
dans la hâte de profiter des derniers
moments de leur soif
d'aventure prévisible avec une autruche
en train de couver elle s'enfuit avant
que l'on ait le temps de la
filmer alors nous allons un petit peu
jouer avec
elle et ce pour connaître sa vitesse
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire il faut la
faire courir
ouais et bien elle faisait du 55 à
l'URE
elle s'est fatiguée très rapidement la
pauvre et c'est la raison pour laquelle
vous pouvezvous l'admirer en gros plan
mais il est juste qu'elle retourne à sa
progéniture et courtoisement que je vous
souhaite une bonne
soirée IR Chag vous a proposé voyage
sans passeport cette émission a été
réalisée avec le concours di schw script
Marc montage Ren gar son claud gson
illustration sonore Dominique paladil
réalisation Solange
pter